de los tres misiles lanzados hoy desde
el líbano dos impactaron en territorio
israelí y uno no salió del territorio
libanés en el momento en que sonaron las
alarmas
el ejército israelí devolvió el golpe
con tres rondas de disparos de
artillería y es que la frontera norte
con el líbano es una frontera muy
delicada israel no quiere que se
convierta en lo que se ha convertido en
los últimos años la frontera sur con
gaza con ataques y represalias continuas
que también han dado en escalada bélica
estas estos ataques de esta mañana han
puesto en guardia al ejército israelí y
además el ejército israelí declara que
seguramente no sea hezbollah quien
estaba lanzando estos misiles hezbollah
recordemos es la milicia chiita libanesa
que además de está financiada por iran
sino que consideran en israel que han
sido probablemente operativos palestinos
desde hace tiempo se intenta han
intentado jamás levantar operaciones de
milicias allí en el líbano israel ha
tratado o ha conseguido acortar las casi
todas eso pensaban
ha habido lanzamientos de misiles de
palestinos probablemente desde el líbano
el último fue el día 20 de julio y ahí
el gobierno israelí prometió que no iba
a permitir que esa frontera fuera
vulnerable y que iba a atacar duro hoy
ha sido probablemente un ejemplo de ello